compound interest is basically the idea
that let's say if you're earning 10 a
year the first year you make 10 and you
end up with let's say you had a dollar
you invested you end up with a dollar
10. but the next year you end up with a
dollar 21 and the next year you end up
with a dollar 32 or 33. so it keeps
adding on itself in such a way that if
you're compounding at 30
a year for 30 years
you don't just end up with you know 10
or 20 times your money you end up with
thousands of times your money so
compound interest is a very powerful
concept but compound interest applies to
more than just compounding capital uh
compounding capital
is just it's just the beginning
compounding business relationships is
very important if you look at some of
the top roles in society like why does
someone get to be a ceo of a public
company or be on the board of a public
company or why does someone get to be a
banker who's managing a billion dollars
is because people trust them and they
trust them because the relationship in
which they've worked the work they've
done it's kind of compounded they've
stuck with the business and they've
shown themselves in a visible and
accountable way to be high integrity
people so compound interest can also
happen in your reputation if you have a
sterling reputation and you do a good
job with it and you keep doing that for
decades upon decades people will notice
that and your reputation will literally
end up being thousands to tens of
thousands of times as valuable as
somebody else who is actually very
talented but is not
keeping a kind of compound interest game
and reputation going
this is also true when you're working
with
individual people so if you've worked
with somebody
at in a business whether your co-worker
and you work together for five or ten
years and you still enjoy working with
them obviously you trust them the little
foibles are gone all the negotiations
that normally would happen to business
relationships can work very very simply
because you just trust each other you
know it'll work out
for example there's another angel in
silicon valley uh eli gill who i like to
do deals with and the reason i love
working with illah is because i know
that when the deal is being done he will
bend over backwards to give me extra he
will always round off in my favor if
there's an extra dollar being delivered
here or there if there's some cost to
pay
he'll pay it out of his own pocket and
he won't even mention it to me and
because he goes so far out of his way to
treat me so well i send him every deal
that i have i try and include him in
everything and then i go out of my way
to try and pay for him
so that relationship just ends up so
powerful that the oneplus one is more
than two as investors here
so compounding in those relationships is
is very valuable even like fitness and
health
many of you have probably been on
various diets and nutrition programs and
exercise programs and you probably
noticed that it takes a little while
before you kind of go through these
growth spurts and then once you've gone
through a spurt you kind of landed a new
level either you're thinner or you're
more muscular and then you can jump up
to the next level from there obviously
fitness we're talking about
physiological compound interest is not
going to work anywhere near as strongly
as it will in the purely intellectual
domain but in the intellectual domain
compound interest rules
even when you look at a business a
business that may have a hundred users
but is growing at a compound rate of 20
percent per month will very very quickly
stack up to having millions of users and
sometimes even the founders of the
companies are surprised by how large the
business scales so when you find the
right thing to do when you find the
right people to work with then just
investing deeply into that and sticking
with it for decades is really how you
make the big bucks and you make the big
returns in your relationships and in
your money this is the most important
chart in the entire deck
there are two concepts in here that
explain everything in mastery the first
on the left side is the compound math
chart and the second is the mastery step
function chart
compound math is by far the most
important force in the universe and you
have to get on the right side of it as
early as you possibly can and this
applies to literally everything in your
life
whether it's capital
ability
insights contacts the setup of this
curve on the left side is on the x-axis
is time on the y-axis is ability capital
context whatever is the function that
needs to be to be compounded
most times in capital markets we're
compounding capital it's wisdom insights
frameworks all of the things in here
this is the most important part of the
entire part of your curve and your
learning curve so the point there are
many in this chart the first is the
gradient starts and it's almost
difficult to see it on the left side of
this curve
because it's like you're learning and
your the amounts that you're compounding
off are still small but over time it
becomes incredibly steep and the point
is here at year 5 year 10 year 15 or
year 30 in your reunions
the marked difference between those who
control their curves and those that
didn't becomes
exponentially literally more pronounced
so i implore you
and learning is the is the topic of
today it applies as much to capital it
applies as much to to contact
if you can control your eye i is the
gradient of that curve and n is how long
you stay on that curve
you will be extraordinarily successful
in your life but you must control your
eye
and you have to lengthen your end
there is no exception to this rule
i'm going to call call some others on
the right side here so please
or one call
chime in here uh through the chat room
if you wouldn't mind i can't see all the
380 people that are on this call at this
point
this is the mastery step function chart
the x-axis here is time the y-axis here
is ability
i want to ask and please jump on if
anyone wants the company where does
mastery live in this chart
clifford i'm going to cold call you in
one minute if i don't see someone on
there
so brendan burns can you please chime in
and uh
announcer here
yeah i just said it probably isn't
anywhere on the chart because you never
attain mastery
fantastic and where are you calling in
from brendan i'm right outside of
philadelphia thank you very much
so the point is here there are many
different answers to that question and i
love yours brendan
the the key insight i wanted to share
with you here is
so these are step function increases in
ability
these are controlled and uncontrolled
leaps i call them the uncontrolled leaps
is where you have aha moments your brain
has a piece of insight that solves
complex problems that you are literally
rewiring your brain
you are different once you've solved
that equation or you have that insight
than you were before
however
those insights those abilities start
fading over time
engulfing analogies
it's very easy to go from 120 to 110 to
100 but as you go down towards 70 or par
the increments become smaller and
smaller and the plateaus become longer
and longer
the point is the masters actually live
on the plateaus
you never get as brendan said to the end
point mastery and the whole pursuit of
mastery is the journey there is no end
point
the point is the masters don't get bored
they recognize that plateaus is part of
the journey
the other key insight here is masters
learn to control their leaps
an uncontrolled leap is what i said
before it's where the amalgam of your
experiences create this burst through of
insight and it literally rewires your
brain
the controlled leaps is where you create
environments that create that leap in
capability
so many of you are coming to business
school or various other institutions to
compress their learning
and increase those controlled leaps
that's literally what they're doing for
those of you who are leaving business
school or others and about to enter the
workforce this is something you must
control
this is the determinant effectively the
mastery step function curve is tiny sub
parts of this exponential curve
you must control this curve
and the more time you invest time and
money to control this step function
chart will determine the quality of your
outcomes and the quality of your life
when i started doing the book
i definitely had the agenda item i'd
like to drum up business
and i was lucky enough to have been
around some great people
that and i'd read the um autobiography
of mahatma gandhi where he talks about
within the first third of the book about
going with prostitutes so here's a guy
writing his autobiography he's a leading
man of india he's revered as a saint and
he wants to tell the world that he slept
with prostitutes and i thought well if
he can be that honest
um maybe i should be honest too and but
i started off the project
hoping to drum up business or at least
having that as somewhere as an agenda
item and i was lucky enough to realize
that it was more valuable for me
and i i would live a more meaningful
life if i was authentic and honest than
if i kind of tried to sort of cover up
some things that i didn't like but
so i think there was a lot of stuff that
gets told by the financial industries
the american public which is just sales
talk this is what they expect to hear
and i think that the financial industry
especially having failed the united
states and the world in 2009
with a lot of rich people in it has an
obligation to be more honest about
what's going on i don't think it's that
hard to do we just got to get more
people doing it but um
but what really blew me away about
so the thank you notes led me to this
guy monish pabrai and i started studying
how
he lived
and i just feel like this technology of
success in life that i feel like i've
uncovered is more valuable than anything
that i learned about investing and i'll
just romp through a few of those really
quickly
um
so some more kind of heuristic rules
like the ants
so i used to try and sell to people at
cocktail parties and i figured out a
very it's again it's like the don't take
sales calls it's like meet somebody do
something for them see how they respond
and there's there's basically i mean i
guess the give-and-take book does it
very well by adam grant but there is
there are the takers the matches and the
givers and you do so i do something for
someone you figure out very quickly
whether they're uh takers or matches
takers or matches we want to
de-emphasize in our lives
givers we want to spend all the time we
possibly can around givers and there's
an example of you know at first when you
start giving like that
you get all the takers they get drawn to
they got drawn to me and so there's a
lot of sorting that goes on a lot of
ways in which you have to get them out
of your life
but then over over time and i'm talking
about
five or ten years i suddenly find myself
surrounded by people who give all around
me and that sets the conditions for
success and so here's something else i
think is
i get really excited about this so
all of the stuff that i did
having uncovered these ideas
are ideas that i could have never
justified to any marketing department
because it looks like totally wasted
money
and
so we have this it's an incredible
opportunity for any individual or
anybody who controls their lives that we
have this incredible bias in the world
towards activity that you can show a
return in a relatively short period of
time because no manager of any business
or any marketing department is going to
be able to stick around if he's
investing in unless it's a very unusual
business
if if he's doing investments they're
going to take you know he says well it
may never pay off but it might take 10
years and i feel like
many of the activities that i've done
are things that i started with no payoff
and then we have this sort of like very
very a slope that is a little bit better
than what it would have been and it's
imperceptible and we think in linear
terms and most people just discard it
and if you're willing to just keep doing
those things for like 10 years
then
suddenly that that slope because it's
it's it's it's growth it's not linear is
pulling away from the slope that it
would have been on and when people start
noticing it
it's 10 years out and then they
misattribute so these that's one simple
idea of sort of getting a slightly
better crowd of people around us
um
you know i mean brene brown has talked
about being vulnerable
i never understood that empathizing to
people is a business tool and time and
again i've realized that just
rather than just
i mean it happened to me the other day
so i met a journalist
who writes for the huffington post
called dory clark i showed up and all i
wanted to do was talk about my book and
instead i had from some miraculous
divine inspiration
i held back and i actually even though
it was set up in such a way that what i
had to do was download
uh to her here's what you need to write
about my book for the huffington post
or forbes or a couple of other
publications i held back and i just said
tell me who you are i spent you know we
spent
um
half an hour talking about two books
that she's written that i hadn't had the
wherewithal to read up upon which i
should have done and she realized she
had somebody who was actually interested
in her
and it wouldn't necessarily have
happened in all cases but um
she ended up inviting me to an author
dinner and i found a friend and that was
a much better relationship and there's
something that can grow out of that
there's optionality that can come out of
that i never understood that uh that
idea of empathy is actually a great
business tool and i think that if you're
wrong environment it definitely is not
going to work if you're around givers it
definitely will work and
the same with being vulnerable when i
sat at my stood at my partnership
meeting they said how do you sell what
is your sales
uh uh what was it what is your process
for selling stocks i say i said in front
of my partners i said i actually have a
very bad process i don't know how to do
it well i don't believe anybody does it
well
in this world people are drawn to that
and over time that accumulates so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you